un terremoto sacudió la costa noreste de
japón con una magnitud de 7,3 revivió el
temor del de hace 11 años
qué ocasionó un desastre nuclear en
fukushima y un tsunami que dejó casi
20.000 muertos sin embargo no se
reportaron daños por el momento no se
identificado ninguna irregularidad en
las centrales nucleares de onagawa y
fukushima número 2 todavía estamos
comprobando el estado de la central
nuclear de fukushima número 1 el sismo
se produjo a una profundidad de 60
metros y a 275 kilómetros de tokio donde
también se sintió más de 2 millones de
casas se quedaron sin electricidad
700.000 de ellas en la capital según la
compañía eléctrica de tokio tras el
temblor se emitió un aviso de tsunami
para las costas de fukushima y miyagi
también emitieron órdenes de evacuación
en algunas ciudades del noreste y la
ciudad de riffo en miyagi abrió refugios
en sus edificios oficiales las
autoridades pidieron estar alerta como
por favor estén atentos a los terremotos
con escalas de intensidad de 6 o
superior durante la próxima semana en
particular los terremotos fuertes suelen
producirse de dos o tres días después
del terremoto anterior japón se
encuentra en el cinturón de fuego del
pacífico una zona de intensa actividad
sísmica que se extiende por el sudeste
asiático y por la cuenca del pacífico el
país se ve afectado regularmente por
terremotos y cuenta con estrictas normas
de construcción destinadas a garantizar
que los edificios puedan soportar los
movimientos telúricos